foreign
hi Janet how are you
I'm good how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
uh I'm calling about a previous episode
I need a little clarification on there
was a woman that had called in and child
had uh basically disowned them and they
were conflicted on the will and taking
them out and you mentioned it as kind of
a grieving
um period for the loss of the parents
feel which makes sense but you both go
in the past that if you're not leaving a
child something in the will then
um you need to be the bigger person and
say you know what you're out uh how do
you do that if they're not speaking to
you I wouldn't do that if they're not
speaking to you the one I've said that
in the past it wasn't a universal
blanket every single time you tell
someone but if someone is misbehaving
and you're communicating with them or
they're not you know behaving in a way
that is honoring to you your values your
family and so you're not going to leave
them in an example would be
um I mean you got a kid doing heroin but
you're trying to love them and you're
still talking to them I'm going to tell
them I'm not leaving you money for
heroin
because I love you
and you need to know that you're not
going to be in there but a kid who won't
speak to me
uh I don't have any you know you don't
need to a person who won't speak to you
you don't need to let them know that
they're not in the will like in other
words Janet I'll talk to you so I'm not
but prior to the day I've never talked
to you and if I wasn't in your will you
didn't need to let me know
right right and that makes sense but
like to not leave a bunch of stress for
the other child that's involved would
you then suggest there's like a letter
with the lawyer yeah yeah I'd leave a
letter with them and just go you know if
you want to be mad at somebody be mad at
me but you decided you didn't want a
relationship with me which means you
don't want a relationship with anything
to do with me and so I I hate that and
I'm sad about that and I've been sad
about that since it happened but uh as a
result I didn't we didn't feel like it
was a proper to leave money to someone
that hates us
okay that's fair uh one more thing
George told me to call in so I wanted to
say thanks to him for that and he does
not have a punchable face that's
somebody else
punchable face I said that on air when
we were commenting about my viral Tick
Tock and I said I think they just hate
me I've got a punchable face they come
for me in the comments and so she's just
defending that because I never said you
had a punchable face Dave would never no
but I'm just saying I was telling him I
might have punched you but I wouldn't
have said anything about it well and I
was just telling him that that's them
projecting what they don't like about
themselves
you're exactly right welcome to
understand that welcome to tick tock
commenters you've got the psychology
down Janet
so yeah it's a it's a it's an
interesting nuance and a good question
thank you for calling in
you know and the Beautiful part about uh
the holidays is we get to see you and
deal with family the horrible part about
the holidays is we get to see and deal
with family
um so in some cases and so uh that
brings up a lot of these
estate questions and I think it's a good
thing to talk about
um
if someone else says it out loud it
doesn't sound as crazy as maybe or as
shame inducing as it sounds in your head
so
um you know the way we stand on things
around here you and I have talked about
this many times George and and uh is
that uh you are under no moral legal or
ethical obligation to leave anyone your
money
period That's a good one to start with
okay and you are under no
uh you have no moral entitlement
to Mama's money
that is the underlying issue yeah
because they're scared of what are the
kids going to think and is it going to
cause resentment and will the
relationships be hurt
and uh you know hopefully you don't
raise entitled kids which luckily you
didn't Dave and so but I mean here's the
thing like the lady that called the
other day her daughter will no longer
speak to her uh over an argument they
had during covid that she wanted to come
visit and give her a hug and she said
not in my house you can't touch us you
don't you're coming to kill us and so
you know crazy coveted people right and
so they they refuse to let the mom and
dad come and refuse to let them see
their grandkids and then it escalated
further and just don't even call we
don't want to talk to you and it's been
since covet they hadn't spoken and so
she said do I leave her in the will and
I said I wouldn't no no you have no she
has no rights and you have no obligation
and it's not about you hitting back I'm
angry at you so I'm taking you out of
the will it's not about manipulating
because we're not really going to call
her and discuss it with her we're not
trying to manipulate anybody it's a
matter of God gave me this batch of
money to manage I manage it for him
so what does the owner
require of this it requires no first and
foremost that I leave it to someone else
who will also manage it for him that's
wisdom first and foremost
so if you decide uh you know like we're
Christians at our house and so as for me
and my house that's who we are and so if
you decide that you're going to worship
a tree or whatever it is you're going to
worship
um and not worship God then
I represent him I manage stuff for him
and why would I leave a tree worshiper
God's stuff
I'm not going to do that
I don't dislike trees but I don't
worship them and so I never thought I'd
hear that sentence on the show yeah
there you go here we are you have to
have to have lots of clarity for the
tree people but the uh um you know so
the but the point is it would be
inconsistent with your values
and what your beliefs are
and so don't ask don't be obligated by
bloodline only to do something that
otherwise sounds crazy because it is
crazy that's why it sounds crazy it's
something to remember it sounds crazy
it's because it's crazy it is it's like
the old thing uh uh you know a guy used
to work here would say you say you know
if you're dating a girl and she says I'm
not crazy that's a sure sign that she's
crazy right that's a red flag that's a
red flag right there you know that one's
crazy and so if something sounds crazy
it's usually because it is if it feels
crazy it's usually because it is if it
feels weird and awkward and not right
it's usually because it's weird awkward
not listen to that voice yeah and so you
know I don't want to leave money to a
kid who won't speak to me because she's
pissed about me wanting to give her a
hug during covet well that Perfectly
Natural but I feel bad why do you feel
bad
I you know I don't feel bad at all I
don't leave strangers and people that
don't talk to me and people that are mad
at me I don't pick out trolls on Twitter
and leave them money that would be a
strange people that have people that
hate me why would I people that don't
want to talk to me people that are mad
at me people that dislike me people that
disrespect me why would I leave them
money that doesn't make any sense at all
and so give yourself a pass give
yourself a get out of jail free card on
the shame and increase the baggage that
goes with inheritance during the
holidays